if you had to boil down the all-stars
three experience into one word what
would it be hmm that was it all right
hallelujah are coming back to our TV
screens I am so excited back you know
I'm that girl that returns so I'm very
happy yes but now we're returning on a
different level
yeah why it was all-stars three the
right all-stars for you because I can't
imagine this is the first time they've
called you up and been like hey we're
doing all-stars well you know it's my
third time back
this is all-star season three and I'm
just really excited you know I'm excited
your lucky number yes
three is my looking over Beyonce's is
four and three is mine
well hello who could this be
looks like the box got an upgrade and so
did I when you walked into that workroom
and you saw the other ladies that were
there what did you think oh I got this
you know you first see everyone you
haven't seen anymore everyone in a while
it's like a family reunion almost I was
like where is the potato salad
you know it's fabulous who did you
consider your biggest threat though you
know when it goes to a lip-sync Kennedy
Davenport is someone that when I first
turned 18 I was going to the clubs in
Dallas and it would live for all she's
the dancing diva of Texas so in a
lip-sync I know that she turns the party
hotcakes split she's a gymnast okay
Dominic dolls eat your heart out cuz
that girl's gonna start flipping a twist
and a turn it and then you look around
everyone's very creative and has their
own creative niche so I know that Trixie
Devils in music and she's an artist in
that so if we have a musical challenge
I'm like okay so she's gonna really
understand that when I've also produced
music something okay either maybe I
should try and partner with her and
she's my friend too
so it's just interesting you every girl
has their own unique gifts so you try to
like okay let's size it up for this
week's runway category is redemption
we're giving you a chance to do over
your most infamous drag race fashion
fails
I've got a lot of those it's very
secretive this year aren't they holding
that back up there double-oh-seven CIA
undercover I can say for sure that fans
should always expect to not expect the
expected I just know that there will be
twists turns conflict drama and
foolishness all that wrapped into that
you can put glitter on the top of it and
that's what Paul's drag race all-stars
carry how would you say other than just
being six years in the game now how have
you changed since your first time
competing well I mean if you have season
two anywhere take a look and you'll know
I walked in that room with a dream but
no makeup but you know I've just learned
so much I've learned more about myself
as a drag professional and what that can
be and who I am who is she and what does
she represent what does she love what
does she not love and what does she like
to give on stage and that's why I get my
life you know I get my life on stage in
front of an audience this is how you
steal the show
[Applause]
I'm a professional I did not get to this
place just because you know it was given
to me I've earned this spot and now I'm
telling appall giving my crown
ok look at this hair this is Crowl ready
wig ok let's do it just missing a little
yeah do it you thank you I don't need a
tiara I want a full-on crown Denair it